هذا وقالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
كارين جومبير ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
امر بتقديم مساعدات امريكيه لمواجهه اثار
الزلزال الذي ضرب مناطق في تركيا وسوريا
واضافت جنبير في مؤتمر الصحفيه نواشنطن
بصدد نشر فرق اضافيه لدعم جهود البحث
ولانقاذ في تركيا وتلبيه احتياجات
المصابين
بسبب الزلزال
استجابه فوريه من الولايات المتحده والى
جانب الافراد الامريكيين الموجودين حاليا
على الارض فنحن بصدد نشر فرق اضافيه لدعم
جهود البحث والانقاذ في تركيا وتلبيه
احتياجات المصابين والنازحين بسبب الزلازل
كما يساهم الشركاء الانسانيون المدعومون
امريكيا في جهود الاغاثه في سوريا منذ
التقارير الاولى عن وقوع زلزال الليله
الماضيه عمل المسؤولون الامريكيون عن كثب
مع تركيا حيث تواصل مستشار الامن القومي
سوليفان مع ناظره التركي ليله الماضيه
هذا اقل المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
بمساعده تركيا على الاستجابه لتداعيات
الزلزال الذي ضرب عده مناطق جنوبيه البلاد
اضاف برايس خلال مؤتمر صحفيا لمساعدات
الامريكيه ستشمل جانبي الحدود التركيه
والسوري وسيستفيد منها المتضررون من
مواطني البلدين
ملتزمون بعمل ما في وسعنا على جانبي
الحدود لمساعده حلفائنا الاتراك على
الاستجابه لتداعيات الزلزال ليس فقط جهود
الانقاذ والاغاثه التي ستبدا قريبا ولكن
ايضا عبر تمويل جهود التعافي وينطبق هذا
على الجانب الاخر من الحدود حازمون على
القيام بكل ما في وسعنا لتلبيه الاحتياجات
الانسانيه للشعب السوري لقد فعلنا ذلك على
مدار 12 عاما وقدمنا مليارات الدولارات
ونقوم بذلك الان بطرق مختلفه في تركيا
لدينا شركائنا وهم الحكومه التركيه وفي
سوريا لدينا شركاء من المنظمات غير
الحكوميه للتقديم الدعم الانساني على
الارض
من واشنطن ينظم الينا مراسله الجزيره محمد
الاحمد يعني تصريحات كثيره من المسورين
الامريكيين عن تقديم المساعدات على جانبي
الحدود لكن ما الاجراءات التي اتخذت حتى
الان رسامه فيما يتعلق بسوريا التي توجد
قواعد وقوات امريكيه
زين في الواقع لحد الان هناك تاكيد عن
امريكي على ان الولايات المتحده ستقدم كل
ما يمكن لمساعده ضحايا هذا الزلزال سواء
في تركيا او بالنسبه
لضحايا زلزال على الجانب السوري لكن
بالنسبه لسوريا بالتحديد الولايات المتحده
اكدت على ان هذه المساعدات ستتم عن طريق
المنظمات الانسانيه المدعومه امريكيا ولن
يكون هناك اي تعاون باي شكل من الاشكال مع
النظام السوري في هذا الاطار الخارجيه
الامريكيه اكدت على ضروره ابقاء المعابر
الحدوديه مفتوحه امام حركه المنظمات
الانسانيه من اجل تقديم الضحايا للسوريين
بالتحديد خاصه من الولايات المتحده تعد
اكبر مانح انساني
للشعب السوري في الاثناء البيت الابيض زي
قبل قليل بيان بشان الاتصال الذي اجراها
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن مع نظيره التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
اعرب خلال هذا الاتصال عن تعازيه وتعازي
الشعب الامريكي في بعد هذا الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب تركيا اكد على الاستعداد
الامريكي لتقديم كل ما يمكن لمساعده
الحليف التركي واشار ايضا الرئيس بايدن في
هذا السياق الى ان الفرق الامريكيه تنتشر
بسرعه حاليه من اجل المساعده في عمليات
البحث والاغاثه وايضا تنسيق جهود
الاغاثه بما في ذلك تقديم الخدمات الصحيه
والمتطلبات التعافي الاساسيه ايضا وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكين اجرت
اتصال هاتفي مع نظيره التركي وحمل ذلك
الاتصال نفس المضامين عن التضامن مع تركيا
بشكل كامل التعهد بتقديم كل ما يمكن
لمساعده الجانب التركي الخارجيه الامريكيه
اشارت الى ان الفرق الامريكيه في طريقها
الى تركيا البيت الابيض الشار الى فرقتين
امريكيتين ستتوجهان الى تركيا في الايام
المقبله وبان
القنصليه الامريكيه في اضنه ستستضيف هذه
الفرق ايضا البينتاجون اشار بعد اتصال
هاتفي بين وزير الدفاع ونظيره التركي لان
الطائرات الامريكيه ستساعد في نقل
الفرق الامريكيه التي ستعمل على مساعده
الجانب التركي في جهود الاغاثه
والتعافي طبعا صدرت هناك الكثير من
البيانات من
عدد من الشخصيات من المشرعين الكبار
المشرعين الامريكيين في الكونجرس وايضا
الجانب الامريكي الخارجيه الامريكيه اشارت
ايضا الى انه لا توجد معلومات لحد الان
بشان ضحايا
الامريكيين نتيجه لهذا الزلزال لكن
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
اشار وتوقع ان يرتفع اعداد الضحايا بالنظر
الى قوه هذا الزلزال اذا هناك تاكيد
امريكي ونتوقع مواصله تاكيد امريكي كما
قلت على مواصله التنسيق مع الجانب التركي
في المرحله المقبله من خلال تقديم هذه
المساعدات
والخارجيه اشارت الى انها تبحث مصادر
تمويل اضافيه وهنا زين يشارد دائما في هذا
السياق الى الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه
الدوليه
جهه رئيسيه في تنسيق هذه المساعدات سواء
للجانب التركي وخاصه
للسوريين لان تقديم المساعدات للجانب
السوري او للسوريين في شمال سوريا تحديدا
يتسم بن من التعقيد بالنظر الى تعقيدات
الوضع السوري وبالنظر ايضا الى ان
الولايات المتحده تنسق هذه المساعدات عن
طريق المنظمات الانسانيه وليس التعامل مع
النظام السوري نظام الرئيس بشار الاسد
الذي تعتبر الولايات المتحده بانه نظام
فاقد للشرعيه
وفرضت عليه الكثير من العقوبات وبالتالي
لا نتوقع ان المساعدات الامريكيه التي
ستقدم الى السوريين ستشمل اي مناطق خاضعه
للنظام السوري لكن كما قلت هناك ما هي
التعقيدات الخاصه بالمناطق المعارضه محمد
كما تعلم زين المناطق المعارضه خاضعه
للكثير من
الفصائل المسلحه
منها فصائل مسلحه مصنفه في قوائم الارهاب
الامريكيه وبالتالي
الولايات المتحده ستعمل على ضمان الا تصل
اي مساعدات
امريكيه الى اي فصائل مصنفه في قوائم
الارهاب لكن في نفس الوقت هناك الملايين
من السوريين المدنيين الذين يحتاجون الى
المساعده وبالتالي نتوقع ان يكون هناك
تنسيق مع الجانب التركي
وتنسيق ايضا مع القوات الامريكيه
المتواجده في سوريا
ومن ثم كما قلت هناك تعقيدات كبيره
بالنسبه لتقديم المساعدات الى الجانب
السوري مقارنه مع تركيا لذلك كما قلت
هناك تاكيد امريكي على التنسيق مع تركيا
المرحله المقبله وهذا التنسيق لن يقتصر
فقط على ضحايا هذا الزلزال من الاتراك لكن
بكل تاكيد ضحايا هذا الزلزال على الجانب
السوري من الحدوث زين
محمد الاحمد الجزيره شكرا جزيلا لك